and I am the writer and director of for
samosas which is uh feature film set
here in Artesia which is Los Angeles is
Little India as they call it
so possumosis is about uh unmotivated
Indian American rapper who finds out
that his ex-girlfriend is now engaged to
another man Victoria so we launches this
Heist on her father's grocery store
where he's keeping these blood diamonds
that he's using to prepare for the
wedding so the whole thing is about how
is the heist gonna go how far on people
he's gonna have to get together for this
four people four sort of social rejects
who are down on their luck thank otola
who plays Vinnie who plays the lead
people call me if any people call me
Bank
I don't know the difference anymore
and so where are you going bro
everyone's been saying that the favor
their favorites you know the whole thing
has been you man really that goes those
guys are in the Titanic whatever they
went through it's nothing compared to
what we just did
nothing and so as I was writing this
peace I began to adjust it for him
because I began to think he'd be a
really interesting hero of my story and
action he's not your typical looking
kind of hero that you would normally
expect to have in a movie yes how are
you feeling today I'm feeling wake up
and it's Monday Monday ain't my fun
day pass on your vision that Ravi had
for this film and the people were able
to get together in terms of the amazing
cast and the amazing crew the energy was
there and that shows up on screen the
community that you create when you
undertake any kind of project it's about
the people that you surround yourself
with and about the people that you find
in that process and the friends you make
and the new family that you create Bring
It On in Bring It On in
this was a really special experience it
was really clear people brought their
hearts into this
[Music]
and I just I'm sad when I go home
so thank you all right
definitely wanted to do something that
was quirky and offbeat I wanted to do
something which were involved in South
Asian community and was about the South
Asian American Community you got the
pajab he's doing the dances you got
Elite character doing a song one of the
actors wants to go to Bollywood and so
it's so much of it as well it's about
the celebration of performance too
foreign
[Music]
like obviously being South Asian and for
us to have this representation in a way
that doesn't have you know the story
isn't about being salvation it just
takes place in this environment where we
can celebrate our culture
oh great we got it and I'm always
interested in the quark I'm interested
in the
maybe live on the fringes of society who
are not the heroes who were maybe the
character actors and elevating them in
some ways and making them the leads of
our stories you want to say something to
our to our fans to our people we have
fans yeah it's not just a South Asian
movie It it's about a heist and it's
about somebody who's trying to express
their heart to another human being and I
think that's something we can all relate
to and I think I think that elevates it
Beyond it being just a South Asian
American story guys I just want to say
absolutely incredible
things
working with being weird for three weeks
it's been incredible for you so thank
you thank you thank you thank you thank
you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]